républicain merci monsieur le Président
que nous a dit le président de la
République tout à l'heure d'abord il
nous a dit que la majorité du pays celle
qui s'oppose à sa réforme serait dans le
déni de la réalité et dans l'ignorance
et que lui seul nous conduirait vers la
lumière c'est une insulte une insulte à
l'intelligence des Français il nous a
dit que les manifestants seraient
noyautées par des factions il est allé
jusqu'à les comparer au suprématistes de
Brasilia ou du Capitole c'est encore une
insulte il nous a dit que les syndicats
auraient refusé de négocier ça c'est un
mensonge a déjà répondu Laurent Berger
il nous a dit que nous n'aurions eu
comme contre proposition que
l'augmentation des déficits alors que
aucun de nos amendements n'a été retenu
ni même examiné y compris se tenant aux
cotisations patronales
c'est donc encore un mensonge il nous a
dit que les entreprises ne finançaient
pas les retraites alors là j'ai cherché
et je n'ai vu qu'une seule explication
il a été trahi par son inconscient et en
réalité c'est son rêve mais c'est aussi
un mensonge encore
il nous a dit que les Français ne
voudraient plus travailler et qu'il
remettraient les bénéficiaires du RSA au
travail c'est une insulte à la crise
démocratique qu'il a approfondie à la
crise politique qu'il a ouverte il a
répondu par quoi la perspective de
nouveau débauchage sans doute les
députés qui n'ont pas voté la motion de
censure ça c'est une indécence et nous a
dit vouloir taxer les entreprises qui
rachètent leurs actions sauvez
l'éducation la santé l'industrie sans
jamais préciser ni ou ni corni comment
en revanche il n'a pas manqué de nous
dire que la réforme des retraites serait
appliquée sans délai alors madame la
Première ministre de matinale en 20h en
13h vous le présent de la République vos
ministres vous ne faites qu'à scéner les
mêmes arguments d'autorité la seule
autocritique que vous vous concédez
c'est celle d'une défaillance
pédagogique vous voulez apaiser le pays
je ne crois sincèrement mais il n'y a
qu'une solution rendez aux Français les
deux ans de vie que vous leur voulez
la parole
est au ministre des légumes en charge du
renouveau démocratique porte-parole du
gouvernement monsieur Véran
monsieur le Président Mesdames et
Messieurs les Sénateurs madame la
ministre le rentre Rossignol je vous
appelle pardon je vous appelais madame
la ministre parce que en 2014 vous étiez
ministre délégué auprès de Marisol
Touraine
j'ai été député socialiste
et vous et moi nous avons eu le courage
de soutenir en 2014 une réforme des
retraites portées par le gouvernement
socialiste auquel vous apparteniez et
que j'ai donc soutenu comme
parlementaire socialiste et qui a
pardonné moi du peu allongé la durée de
cotisation pour tous les Français qui
travaillent et vous l'avez fait dans un
souci de justice et vous l'avez fait
avec un objectif équilibré un système de
retraite qui ne l'était plus dans la
durée alors je vous dis ça madame la
sénatrice je pourrais aussi vous
rappeler qu'à l'époque lorsque vous
faisiez partie du gouvernement il y a eu
l'adoption d'un texte important
courageux nécessaire pour l'économie
notre pays adopté par un 49-3 vous étiez
au gouvernement vous ne l'avez pas
quitté j'étais alors député du groupe
socialiste je ne l'ai pas quitté comme
quoi madame
comme quoi je l'ai dit socialiste comme
quoi ça veut dire que vous avez sans
doute la mémoire sélective moi pas
Madame c'est la triche il se trouve
aussi qu'en écoutant votre question j'ai
l'impression que vous avez l'oreille
sélective moi pas ou plutôt l'oreille
déformante jamais le président de la
République n'a comparé les
manifestations avec des factions à aucun
moment il a fait le distingo entre les
manifestations démocratiques dont il a
salué la qualité de l'organisation et la
sécurisation par les organisations
syndicales il la distinguer de groupes
oui madame la sédatrice de violents qui
viennent de l'ultra gauche et qui
sergent qui cherche à saccager nos
villes mais surtout même la sénatrice
parce que nous venons du même bord quand
on vous dit qu'on va augmenter les
petits salaires en dessous du SMIC vous
devez dire oui quand on dit qu'on va
améliorer les fins de carrière pour les
salariés vous devez dire oui quand on
vous dit qu'on va lever une contribution
exceptionnelle pour les grands groupes
quand il rachète des actions vous
devriez dire oui et quand on propose de
conclure de bénéficiaires du RSA loin de
l'emploi en formation ou à l'emploi vous
devriez applaudir avec nous et madame la
sénatrice c'est ça avoir de la mémoire
et du courage et de la conviction dans
la continuité
[Musique]